a very warm welcome
my dear john to the college of
commissioner
and we put on this one so it's a bit
easier
um a very warm welcome now good to see
you again
but good to see you for the very first
time as the united states
special presidential ny for climate it's
it's wonderful to have you here it's
wonderful to have
a good friend back uh in the european
union and it's wonderful to
know that we have a friend again in the
white house
so um special envi for climate
you see here a college of commissioners
and vice presidents who
are working hard on our european green
deal
a bit more than a year ago in december
219
we agreed uh together with 27 member
states heads of state and government
to be in to to commit to the goal to be
in 2050 the first climate neutral
continent
and you know of course with an ambition
comes a road map um come
different milestones in between
now uh we've set the goal in 2030 to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by at
least 55 percent
and behind this dry number is an
enormous amount of work and effort and
transformation
and therefore we were of course
delighted when we saw president biden
his first day in office joining again
the paris climate agreement
and last friday i had the pleasure and
the honor to
have a phone call with president biden
and it was music to my ear
to hear the way he described to me
how the united states are moving towards
the common goal
to become climate neutral
and to put it in a frame where i am
convinced and this college is convinced
that's the right way to go
just to describe that new growth
strategy
for our economies it's a lot of
innovation behind it
there's a lot of new technologies behind
it and this combination of innovation
resources we put in of course people who
expect us to improve on that
is a fascinating one it's um with a lot
of work we have to do together but
it's the right way to go and of course
as europeans we are aware of the fact
that we have to
contribute to the common cause but
we can do it alone and therefore to have
you
at our side as friends and allies is
enormously important for us
another point that struck me um during
this pandemic
is when we speak about climate change we
are often speaking about melting
glaciers
or desertification or extreme weather
situations all these topics are well
known
but this pandemic also taught us that
one of the breeding grounds
for this pandemic is the loss of
biodiversity
and the complex world behind it and
we see now the width of consequences
climate change brings along and the urge
and the necessity for us to really move
forward rapidly
we have an ambitious roadmap ahead of us
this year
it starts with earth day on the 22nd of
april
very much looking forward to that
president biden is inviting
and of course then the roadway map
towards
glasgow in november of this year so
we are very eager here in this college
to listen to you and then of course
engage
in a dialogue in a conversation
discussion on that so a very warm
welcome again
you